en plein coeur de l'enfer d'azov talent
ces images sont tournées par les
combattants du régiment à 9 la dernière
poche de résistance contre l'offensive
russe à mario paul depuis cette usine
métallurgique l'une des plus grandes
d'europe ils tiennent bon en dépit d'un
face-à-face totalement déséquilibrée
pour l'instant ils doivent leur survie
grâce au gigantesque réseau souterrain
du site dans lequel ils s'abritent
depuis plusieurs semaines aujourd'hui
encore il refuse de rendre les armes
chaque jour peut être le dernier c'est
peut-être la dernière fois qu'on se
parle qui ces personnes nous mêmes on
s'en fiche
ce qui nous intéresse c'est notre pays
notre nation et c'est pourquoi on veut
que cette histoire se finisse de la
meilleure des façons
des soldats prêts à donner leur vie pour
l'honneur mais aussi par peur de tomber
aux mains des russes le régiment d'azov
est directement ciblés par la propagande
de moscou à cause de combattants issus
de l'extrême droite qui l'ont composé à
sa création en 2014 leurs proches lance
un appel à l'aide pour les secourir
mon fils est en enfer à azov talent à
l'heure où je vous parle il se bat ce
qui est en train de se passer là-bas
n'est pas une guerre c'est un massacre
c'est une violation de toutes les
conventions internationales c'est le
massacre de personnes qui chaque cas est
unique le deuil d'après la croix rouge
présente à mario paul en plus du
régiment aof au moins cent cinquante
mille personnes n'ont pas encore pu fuir
la ville portuaire